now
if we want to find some good news in the
data it's that democrats
keep gaining on republicans
in 2022 election polling
the numbers are not yet a delight
but they're increasingly looking okay
let's start with the house why start
with the house well democrats are not
favored to keep control of the house
democrats currently control the house of
representatives it is likely that they
will lose the house of representatives
but
the numbers have been improving for
democrats every single day for months
where do the numbers stand now the 538
forecast for the house
says that it's a 74 chance that
republicans take the house and a 26
chance that democrats keep the house but
look at the way the numbers have shifted
if you scroll down on this 538 page
which is a very very uh detailed and
it's a great forecast
you will see a section called how the
house forecast is changed
and you will see that in early june
democrats had a 14 chance of holding the
house that even dropped to 12 in late
june early july
but it has been
a steady but
you know modest surge
almost doubling the odds of democrats
keeping the house going from
actually more than doubling going from a
bottom out of 12 to a 26 chance now
remember
things that are 12 percent likely to
happen sometimes happen
things that are 26 percent likely to
happen sometimes happen but things that
are 74 percent likely to happen are are
more likely to happen by definition so i
can't tell you that i think it's a great
shot for democrats in the house but the
numbers have been improving and if
democrats keep adding on you know one
percentage point chance every other day
between now and november uh that's 30
right that would put this at 50 50 by
election day so that's what's happening
in the house now in the senate things
are looking much better for democrats in
the senate democrats are now 70 percent
chance uh 70 likely to hold control of
the senate whereas republicans are only
30 likely this has gone last week i told
you it was two to one in favor of
democrats it is now two and a third or
you know whatever it's it's well beyond
two to one at this point in time and
again
these are numbers that have improved for
democrats uh there was a point in early
june where democrats had a 40
shot of holding the senate that is now a
70 shot
very very important to understand
because there are people writing to me
saying david why do you keep saying
democrats are going to have 70 senators
and of course david is not saying that
what i am telling you is that it is a 70
chance
that democrats hold the senate the most
likely outcome
is that democrats hold it
51 to 49 that would be a gain of one
seat right now in the senate it's 50 50.
the vice president gets a tie-breaking
vote that's kamala harris so democrats
are in the majority
50 50 plus kamala the most likely
outcome here is a 51 to 49 majority for
democrats so please do not write to me
saying david democrats have no chance in
hell of getting 70 seats
i'm agreeing with you that's not what
the number means that's not what the
number means
but i appreciate everybody writing in so
the bottom line
democrats chances continuing to improve
and if they merely continue improving at
the same rate
the house will end up a 50-50 flip of
the coin by early november we will watch
and see whether that happens